yes because he has a lot to answer for
that he could not ever
answer up about that's another
uh brings up another topic is
a lot of people question you
about david miscavige in regards to the
fact that you've come out about so much
and you were so close to him
how come you haven't been able to give
up enough information to lead to like an
arrest of him or to send him to prison
like people
well i would love to know the answer to
that too
i have talked to every law enforcement
agency that i could possibly
think of and given them everything and
every document and
every everything that i have and i
continue to do so
like uh it's not from from lack of
trying
believe me okay it is not from lack of
trying and
the difficulty always with with
any sort of prosecution or even a legal
case against scientology
is twofold threefold one
scientology will turn it into
a nuclear war and just like
you know there is a a bunch of writings
by l ron hubbard
about making litigation punitive
and what does that mean punishing
the your opponent okay through
litigation okay making
everything uh difficult like
noticing depositions uh appealing every
hearing appealing every order
filing crazy stuff to disqualify the
lawyers to disqualify
judges like anything and everything
to make it as expensive and painful as
possible for anybody to pursue
a legal case against scientology okay
it's a scorched
earth litigation strategy that has
proven
very very effective secondly
scientology has because of what i was
saying to you before
this idea that
saving scientology and or preserving
scientology
is the most important thing for all of
mankind scientologists will lie
if they believe that
saying something would be harmful to
scientology
they won't say it let me give you an
example
when we did the the uh
truth rundown series with joe childs and
tom tobin
at the saint pete times me
marty rathbun tom devock jeff hawkins
bunch of people spoke to them and said
look here are the things that have
happened and you know
part of this is we have witnessed
and experienced ourselves on numerous
occasions
david miscavige being physically violent
with members of the sea organization
that those those
uh
claims were put to scientology
like how do you respond to the fact that
this person this person this person this
person this person this person
they all swear that they have seen this
happen i mean you even claimed in the
hbo documentary that
miscavige physically assaulted you
numerous on numerous occasions right
yeah and it's it's yeah i've said it
over and over
and it absolutely happened and there's
been tons of people that have witnessed
it
and i've witnessed it with tons of other
people and
he seems like a little guy how could he
i don't think he can do that how much
damage could he do
well did you defend yourself no because
if you defend yourself you're attacking
him
okay oh so if you defend yourself you're
attacking scientology
and trying to attack david miscavige who
is scientist
he is scientology right but at the time
a bunch of the people like because joe
and tom
you know they're good reporters they
were like very diligent and they would
say
well tell me who you saw david miscavige
physically assault and so i would say
well i saw him assault makjaegar and mak
ingba and wendell reynolds and ray
middoff and norman starkey
and and i would go through the list and
then independently they would go
to marty rothman say who did you see
david miscavige strike oh i saw him
strike that machine
without me present and then they would
go to tom de vocht and he would say
exactly the same thing so
they verified that this like there's no
way that you can have
people just randomly coming up with
these same stories
right so they wrote as they always did
to scientology and said how do you
respond to the fact that we have
numerous witnesses that say david
miscavige has struck mark yeager
struck raymond off struck blah blah blah
blah blah blah
comes back the answer this is outrageous
these people are all paid liars they're
this they're that
and here are 50 affidavits
signed by those very people all saying
they have never been struck by david
miscavige
and these things are completely
manufactured lies
just fabricated totally fabricated but
in their mind
this is saving and protecting
scientology
and this is a problem when prosecuting
scientology or filing a lawsuit
is and particularly in a criminal case
the standard in a criminal case is
guilty beyond reasonable doubt
if you can create reasonable doubt
you have to be found right not guilty
and reasonable doubt in the mind of a
prosecutor
and they're not used to this
five people come in and say this
happened
and then scientology gets wind of it
for whatever reason and they will have
50 or 100 people
give signed under penalty of perjury
affidavits saying it never happened
and they go how do we prosecute a case
like this
[Music]
and it's sort of the hard thing which
what for prosecutors to understand to be
able to put together a case
when they always have to
you know make decisions about where are
they going to invest their resources
what are they going to put their time
and effort into
yeah are they going to be able to to get
an
actual guilty verdict and
so this is why now
after you know the the expose
in the tampa bay times and going clear
and then subsequently in the aftermath
david miscavige doesn't appear anywhere
anymore
right because his
his weakness is that if he
has to testify under oath
he may get enough he may get people to
lie
with him but particularly in a civil
case
that may not be good enough and
he can't answer up for certain things
and there are
things that he he doesn't want to have
to answer up to
right and so he stays out of sight and
you know it's some comfort to me
that he now has to live the life of a
hermit right
you know i may be being harassed
and they may say shitty things about me
all the time and follow me
and do whatever but i just live my life
are you still being harassed to this day
absolutely well you just said it
yourself
look up my name google my name and
you'll see a bunch of ads from
scientology about how i'm a wife beater
my daughter is out has a website and is
and she's a sea org member by the way
yeah how [ __ ] up is that situation
your whole family it's crazy my my son
my daughter my ex-wife my brother my
sister
all of these people are out there saying
you know what a horrible person i
am that i'm a um a wife beater
that i sh shake babies that i
i'm a womanizer that i'm a this that i'm
like
whatever and again this is
pursuant to the scientology idea
that i'm a bag man for satan
and that destroying me is good for the
world
and that hubbard says that anybody who
is a
critic of scientology and he wrote a
thing about this that's on my blog
has crimes they have felonies
in the background and this has been
proven over and over and
even if you don't know what the felony
is you can be
absolutely safe accusing them of
committing felonies because
whether you got the right one or not
doesn't matter
so this is how
scientology goes about things they
do disconnecting right yeah that's
disconnection that's like
and that's back to the theory of the
bad things happen to you when you're
connected to sources
of suppression and sources of
suppression is someone like me
yeah so my children
my mother my brother my sister
all the rest of my family because if
they want to remain scientologists
they must disconnect from me and because
my daughter
and son are both in the sea organization
they must carry out whatever they are
told to do
in order to try and get me
dismissed as an attacker have you tried
reaching out to them
absolutely i went one time
my son at one point after i had left the
sea organization
uh had cancer and i was unaware of it
because nobody communicated to me
and in fact joe childs called me up the
reporter from the
saint pete times and said i just got off
the phone with a lawyer for scientology
and they said you're such a shitty
person
that you didn't even try and see your
son when he had cancer
he said he has cancer he said yeah i was
afraid of that
you didn't even know and i said no i had
no idea
so i drove to the fort harrison i was
living in
palm harbor i drove to the fort harrison
i went to the front door i said i want
to see my son
i understand he has cancer i want to see
him
they called the police and issued a
trespass warning on me and sent a pie
out to spittle
bursting get off the property get off
the property
and i was basically escorted from the
premises
and that was the that was the second
last time
and the last time i had any interaction
with my daughter and ex-wife was
when they followed me to a doctor's
office that's just off gulf to bay
where my wife was seeing the doctor and
i was standing in the parking lot
waiting for her
in fact talking on the phone at the time
with a reporter from the bbc
and my brother from australia my ex-wife
from l.a
my daughter from four senior officials
of scientology and two private
investigators showed up and started
screaming at me
and jesus christ this is
it's such a fascinating story because
i'm on the phone with the bbc
and they said john you have you'll never
guess who just showed up here
guillaume la serve dave bloomberg
my my daughter jenny lindsen blah blah
blah blah
and then you hear the screaming start
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you piece of [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] blah blah blah
and ultimately this resulted in
uh like i tried to leave
i tried to walk i'd been walking around
talking to him on the phone i tried to
get back to my car
and they sought to prevent me from
leaving and then took the keys out of my
car and threw him away
and it was like this whole sort of
insane thing that's all recorded on
audio
and um in the course of that
my ex-wife got a graze on her arm when
she was trying to prevent me from
closing the car door